Democrats prepare for an Iowa showdown
at Trump and Bluebird go at each other
and the Super Bowl halftime show does
deja vu I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show this show is sponsored by
expressvpn don't like the government
spying on you and making sure what
you're doing with your data
well visit expressvpn comm slash pens
who stay safely anonymous
all righty today is the day Iowa
caucuses I know you all enjoyed the
Super Bowl last night well those of you
who didn't see the halftime show I
understand that yesterday was a time to
get together and have our secular
national holiday and all of this but
this week man this week I hope you drank
heavily because they're gonna need all
of that alcoholic intake stored in your
body for I would say siphoning out this
week I mean I think that we're gonna
need to draw on that all this week
because here's they all got the Iowa
caucuses tonight and then tomorrow we
have the State of the Union address and
sometime during this week this whole
impeachment thing is going to end we'll
get to all of those topics in just one
second the big topic and of course is
what happens in Iowa because right now
the human being who seems to be most
likely to win the Iowa caucuses by
polling data is at Barnard at max Anders
the octogenarian socialist loom bag who
believes that there are too many
different types of deodorants and if
there weren't as many types of deodorant
then perhaps the homeless people
wouldn't be homeless that guy is
probably gonna win Iowa he's also
probably gonna win New Hampshire and
right now polling has him within five in
South Carolina so that means that he is
there's a significant possibility that
Bernard mix Anders is your nominee now
Joe Biden is stacking this whole thing
up for a long run he says don't worry
guys this is gonna take a while
that is him basically conceding Iowa
ahead of time cuz if Joe Biden wins Iowa
this thing is also over very early
because if Joe Biden wins Iowa and
Bernie goes on to win New Hampshire it
is likely that Biden with withstands
Bernie's run in Nevada withstands him in
South Carolina and all of this is
basically coming down to a Biden versus
Bernie battle with Bloomberg waiting
somewhere in the wings hoping that Biden
completely collapses in Iowa and New
Hampshire and then he becomes sort of
the moderate choice which is why he was
dumping hundreds of millions of dollars
into advertising including tens of
millions of dollars into advertising on
Superbowl Sunday well Bernie has been
drawing enormous crowds in Iowa which
really matters in Iowa because to caucus
state so normally you don't associate
crowd size with victory
member republicans made this mistake in
2012 right before the 2012 election
Mitt Romney drew like 20,000 people to a
rally in Pennsylvania I remember
covering it and people were like wow
that is amazing that's huge he's gonna
beat up and then you just got walloped
by Obama right I mean he he won by Obama
want my fewer votes than he had over
McCain but it was still a very very
large victory for President Obama well
in Iowa it's a little bit different
because enthusiasm really does matter
now there are a few things to keep in
mind in Iowa one Iowa is he
disproportionately old state so while we
are talking about all the young people
who are showing up for Bernie Sanders
and their enthusiasm in the organization
the ground game and all that the truth
is that Iowa like most of the United
States is growing disproportionately old
according to the New York Times
Iowa's outsized role in presidential
politics is often criticized for
precisely that reason but Iowa mirrors
the nation's economy and demography in
one very striking way the state's
rapidly aging population and the myriad
economic political and social
consequences that flow from it the state
is is largely known for corn and
soybeans but it also is sort of
bifurcated between the rural Iowa areas
and the urban Iowa areas it is
increasingly driven by the impacts of it
the aging population 20 years ago Iowa
had one of the oldest populations in the
nation its senior population has grown
rapidly since then now the nation's
older population is growing even faster
now today Iowa is in the middle of the
pack when it comes to ranking states by
age with that said right now well over
20 percent of the Iowa population is
over the age of 60 so what that means is
that those are Joe Biden voters and
bottom line is those are all Joe Biden
voters if you look at the polling data
Joe Biden polls in the single digits
among young voters who are Democrat
among old voters who are Democrat Bernie
Sanders pulls in the single digits so
although old people are like yeah we
remember communism and won that great we
remember when the USSR was around when
Cuba was a thing and like we don't want
that here and when we're not into the
Democratic Party moving in that
direction we remember how when for
George McGovern so we're just not going
to do that
younger Democrats who are very enthused
about the idea of pie in the sky dream
is being made public and all of this
they're very into Bernie Sanders so
bernie is drawing these massive crowds
but that may not actually be indicative
of how the iowa vote goes depending on
whether the old people show up and
traditionally the old people show up see
bernie is
that young people gonna show up in
numbers that they haven't before he's
betting on bringing new audiences out
typically people who bet on new
audiences particularly young audience is
showing up on mass typically that
doesn't happen now Barack Obama in 2008
did get new audiences to show up to vote
for him but those audience were
disproportionately minority meaning that
black voters showed up in droves to vote
for Barack Obama in 2008 which makes
sense he was the first major ticket
national black nominee I mean the idea
that they were going to be able to vote
a black president into the White House I
mean black populations looking at a
prospective black president saying okay
I'm showing up to vote for that guy
that's not shocking and shouldn't be
surprising for anybody but the idea that
young people are gonna show up in droves
to vote for the old guy even if that
holds true in the primaries that may not
hold true in the general election see
there's this whole myth making that's
happening right now in American politics
where Donald Trump activated a brand new
base that had never shown up to vote
before and if you look statistically
that really isn't the case Donald Trump
performed almost exactly in line with
Mitt Romney across the board the
difference is that no one showed up to
vote for Hillary Clinton the dirty
little secret about 2016 is that it was
all about nobody showing up to vote for
Hillary Clinton not about Donald Trump
magically activating some heretofore
unknown base who showed up to vote for
him and that was that there was there
were a small number of voters who were
that but it wasn't this vast
overwhelming wave Bernie Sanders
counting on young people to show up in
droves and then vote for him
it's a risky strategy for sure now it
could happen in Iowa because small
sample size now polling in Iowa is
notoriously fickle and this is why it
does matter an awful lot that just
before the Iowa caucuses there is now a
Des Moines Register and CNN scrapped
their final Iowa poll according to Axios
this is the gold standard poll published
by the Des Moines Register for 76 years
and the the gold standard is no longer
available so CNN that I'm one register
and seltzer and company announced they
would not be releasing the final
installments of the CNN Des Moines
Register Media compo a respondent raised
an issue with the way their interview
was conducted which could have
compromised the results of the poll and
they were unable to ascertain what
happened during the respondents
interview and they couldn't determine if
this was a single isolated incident her
political the survey has the power to
fuel a candidate's eleventh-hour
momentum or damage a contender who
underperforms expectations the release
of the results was highly anticipated
because this is so competitive because
you have four candidates or basically
polling within six or seven points of
each other Biden Sanders Elizabeth
Warren and Peabody judge apparently one
respondent told the Buddha judge
campaign the former mayor's name it was
not one of the choices he was offered
the campaign then alerted CNN and other
polling partners and then CNN said a
respondent raised an issue with the way
the interview was conducted and so they
pulled the poll now the Bernie
supporters are basically saying no the
reason you pulled the poll is because
Bernie is winning right and so you don't
want to demonstrate that burning is
winning the Democratic Party doesn't
want to show Bernie that that is
conspiratorial ISM there's very little
evidence to that effect but with that
said the Bernie people are of course the
most adamant and they are the loudest
and they are the and he is drawing the
biggest crowds it's interesting over the
weekend I actually sat down and watched
I wanted to see like a Bernie rally
beginning to end I know I'm really a
masochist so I sat down and I watched a
Bernie rally beginning to end and I
won't tell you about that and I want to
talk about the appeal of Bernie Sanders
which I think Republicans are under
estimating in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that you
probably spend an awful lot of your day
sitting in front of a screen I know I do
I mean I spent a lot of time in front my
computer or looking at my cell phone and
if you do that for long enough your eyes
are going to start to hurt unless you
are using Felix gray blue light glasses
these are great they're really great
especially because if you have trouble
sleeping because you've been viewing
screens too much that blue light is
keeping you awake in all of us
Felix great launched in 2016 with the
singular focus to offer the most
effective computer glasses on the market
they have succeeded because they filter
out 90% of high-energy blue light and
they eliminate 99% of the harsh glare
coming from screens again I've been
using Felix create glasses during my off
hours and makes sure that number one I
look sophisticated like Rachel Maddow
but number two it means that my eyes are
not going to hurt all day when I am
watching when I'm looking at screens
unlike other brands who use cheap blue
light coatings that are ineffective and
can chip or scratch I've actually used
those before and they're garbage
Felix gray contrary uses a proprietary
blue light technology that is embedded
directly in the lens available available
in prescription and non-prescription and
readers
Felix gray has you covered with optical
glasses for work and sleep glasses in
the evening that are clinically proven
to increase in melatonin secretion when
worn leading up to bedtime which is
great I mean you need to wind down
before bed but you're still want to use
your phone well now you can do that
using the Felix Craig glasses why would
you buy glasses from a company whose
sole focus is not making glasses from
some fashion company or something
instead go to Felix great glasses calm
slash Ben and a pair of blue light
glasses from the pros
shipping and returns are totally free so
you really have nothing to lose that's
Fe Li X G RA Y glasses comm slash Ben
Felix gray glasses comm slash Ben and
again shipping and returns are totally
free it's gonna make her life better
Felix great glasses comm slash Ben okay
so I actually watched a Bernie rally
getting Ben and really tells you what
you need to know about the these sort of
Bernie Sanders campaign and that is
everything Bernie Sanders does is about
clinical building a movement if you
watch one of his rallies from beginning
to end
he feels like a 1960 style professor
who's doing a teachin and it's
deliberately created like this I mean
this is what his rallies are created to
do this is how he speaks he has this
sort of were speaking up to the man
we're down we're not just here to stop
Donald Trump we help to build a movement
and then he's very vague about what
exactly the movement constitutes because
it would be very odd if the Soviet
national anthem started playing in the
background or something to give you a
clue so he does this whole teachin
mentality and that means for example
about ten days ago he's at a rally in
Iowa or not even was like six days ago
he did a rally in Iowa Ames Iowa and the
rally opened with the band Portugal the
man playing for him very popular band I
played one of their songs on the show
there they do catchy tunes and one of
their guys gets up at the end of this
and he says you know when I was asked to
play at this Bernie rally well I had one
stipulation that every one of our
concerts we asked indigenous people to
come to the concert and we asked them to
stand up and explain why we were
standing on stolen land see then uh
sure's up three Native American women in
Ames Iowa to explain why Iowa is
actually stolen land right this is the
opener of the Bernie Sanders rallies
that we are standing on stolen land so
basically the foundations of the United
States are evil right that is the that
is the opener at the Bernie Sanders
rally then these Native American women
they get up they talk about all of this
they leave and Michael Moore gets up and
Michael Moore who is indeed a radical I
mean the man made a movie about how the
Cuban health care system is a joy of
joys and a wonder of wonders which is
why everybody in Cuba is trying to
escape from Cuba on a 1957 Chevy with
tires blown up around the sides trying
to float their way to Miami which by the
way is not an easy thing to do right 90
miles of shark-infested waters just to
get away from that wonderful health care
system then Michael Morris Ohio so
Michael more than get
in Michael Moore does this check about
how America is founded in racism and
sexism and bigotry and homophobia and
inequality and how Bernie Sanders is
going to completely revolutionize the
way politics is done right he gets up
and he does his shtick for like 20
minutes
and then after that he uh sure's up
Bernie Sanders and now Bernie looks like
that is well actually I'm sorry
then he ushers up a OSI okay a OSI gets
up and she gets up and she starts
talking about how America is a corrupt
system and AOC again is quite good on
the stump right she's charismatic and
she gets up and she does her stick about
how America is is terrible and America
is awful and how she is for Bernie
because Bernie is the most radical guy
in the field and then she ushers up
burning and Bernie is the elder
statesman right now because you've seen
Portugal the Man three Native American
women explaining that I was bad followed
by Michael Moore who's a crazy person
followed by aoc who's an even crazier
person when they uh sure up Bernie
Bernie seems almost moderate by
comparison with the rest of the rally
because Bernie stick is not the Bernie
that you actually see during the debates
during the debates you got bully yelling
all the time about unfairness and about
health care and America is terrible
during his rallies he speaks instead
like some sort of of UC Berkeley 1968
professor right he it's much more lower
pitch right he it's much lower pitch he
gets up and he says we live in the
country that has serious and equality
and you and I together are going to
build a movement and it sounds much more
reasonable and in it's designed like
this right it's actually quite clever
and again his whole shtick is we're not
just going to defeat Donald Trump who is
the worst person who ever lived but also
we're going to build a movement and this
is why he's got momentum right now
because Joe Biden's case is only
defeating Trump Bernie Sanders's cases
I'm gonna build a movement and that is a
lot more inspiring particularly to young
people now older people are going we
don't need a movement we just need to
stop Trump right we don't like Trump
comes bad but bernie is like no we're
gonna stop Trump and we're going to
build the movement now make no mistake
his first pitch is we're going to stop
Trump and that's the only unifying pitch
he has because the truth is that his
movement is popular with his movement it
is not popular with the bulk of
Americans there's a new poll that came
out that should scare the living
daylights out of Democrats that showed
what Americans think of capitalism
versus socialism and sapote from NBC
News Wall Street Journal released on
Sunday more than half of registered
voters 52 percent have a positive view
of capitalism
18% have a negative perception of
capitalism I don't know what happened to
the other 30% whether they were hit in
the head by a brick or something but the
fact that you live in the greatest
economy in the history of the world and
you live in a capitalist system that is
generated more wealth since 1800 and in
the entire history of humanity combined
and that only fifty two percent of you
think that capitalism is good
demonstrates a real lack of education in
the American system but I will say only
19 percent of voters have a positive
view of socialism
whereas 53 percent have a negative
perception of socialism and Bernie
Sanders openly declares that he is a
socialist right he always says
democratic socialism but he's an actual
socialist in the sense that he still
cannot explain why he would not
nationalize all the industries he said
who would want one nationalize with that
said look Bernie right now in this poll
is leading Trump nationally 49 to 45
that is not enough to be Trump because
when all the votes come in is probably
more like 48 Trump and most of those are
in the swing states whereas Bernie is
racking up big scores in places like
California and New York my places that
already agree with Bernie so if you are
in the Democratic Party base and your
and all you want to do is beat Trump
you're scared but this is why the
primaries are really really a problem
for Joe Biden because the people who are
voting in the primaries are the most
excited they're the people who want to
feel like they're part of a movement
they're the people who are the most
passionate and people who are the
quote-unquote most well educated the
people who follow this stuff the most
closely and those people are in Bernie
Sanders's corners the primaries are
cutting directly against the electoral
interest of the Democrats now with that
said so I think the Republicans who are
rooting for Bernie's nomination are
under estimating him I do I do I think
the Bernie is shockingly shockingly
interesting on the stump like having
again watched one of his entire events
over the over the weekend I think he is
shockingly interesting on the stump I
think that he's he's good at what he
does which is be a useless communist for
his entire life but give you the feeling
that there's a conspiratorial elite
coming after you which is a different
thing then then like Elizabeth Warren
does it but it's louder and it's more
brash and it's not as it we're it's
weird right because if you watch them in
debate you think that that Warren is the
one who's more modulated because in
debate she is but if you watch them on
the stump Warren is a lot less modulated
than Sanders Sanders comes off as softer
spoken on the stump then Elizabeth
Warren does which is really kind of a
fascinating contrast okay but with that
said is it is burr
me in a position where the Democratic
Party upper echelon should be frightened
of him they should they should like I
think Republicans are under estimating
but I also think that it's quite
possible that Bernie got skunked by
Donald Trump and if you're a member of
the Democratic Party elite the fact that
he's building a movement in the
primaries that is not going to carry
over to the general beyond that core is
not going to be super helpful to you and
as you'll see Bernie's people are
actively alienating other elements of
the Democratic Party actively alienating
those other elements we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about safety and security around your
home as you know I am deeply concerned
with safety and security we get death
threats on a fairly regular basis we've
had people you know who are trying to to
to threaten me my wife online in real
well like it's not fun okay this means
that I'm super concerned about safety
and this is why I use ring-ring allows
me to make sure that my property is safe
at all times it means that when somebody
rings the doorbell I know exactly who
they are because I can pick up from
anywhere it doesn't matter from 3,000
miles away
street crime in Los Angeles has been
going up for a lot of people because the
city is horribly run and this has been
happening in major cities all over the
country if you want to keep your house
safe really ring is the place to do it
go check out ring right now they help
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world if there's a package
delivery surprise visitor you get an
alert and you're able to see here and
speak to them all from your phone now as
a subscriber you have a special offer on
the ring welcome kit available at ring
comm slash pen they can include a video
doorbell and the chime Pro which is what
you need to start building a ring of
security around your home today go to
ring.com slash pen that is ring comm so
I spent again are ing comm slash been
ringing calm slash man go check out ring
right now again it'll make your house
safer make your life better go check
them out ring it calms my family use
them and you should do okay so the the
base for Bernie Sanders who is likely
against when the Iowa caucuses tonight
that base is actively alienating other
parts of the Democratic Party so over
the weekend a controversy broke out
after Rasheeda Talib who is a radical
anti-semite and a horrible human being
she was campaigning for Bernie so
campaign but I was amazed there was an
article last week suggesting that Bernie
was upping his Jewish identity in
advance of the 2020 election okay let me
say as somebody who didn't have to up
their Jewish identity right been pretty
clear from the beginning because I wear
the funny hat on my head and everything
right as somebody who doesn't need to
actively up my Jewish
as I'm leveling up in a video game just
in time to pretend that I'm
intersectional Bernie Sanders pretending
that he has any serious association with
Judaism while campaigning with while
campaigning with Linda Sarsour open
anti-semite Ilhan omar open anti-semite
Rashida to leave open anti-semite
hanging out with with the Jeremy Corbyn
nights of the party promulgating an
agenda that includes funding of Hamas
hidden stick it I kind of want to hear
about journey Sanders is Jewish identity
when that has basically amounted to
conveniently pulling out his Jewish
identity to pretend that he's not just a
white guy every few minutes that's
pretty much his only association with
Judaism you don't get to play the I'm a
Jew card after your after your
association with Judaism has basically
been campaigning with anti-semites
throughout your entire career
undermining the State of Israel and
covering for the anti-semitism in your
own party sorry you don't get to do that
that does not hold any water at all
anyway reshoot it to leave is on stage
and this is again at one of these Bernie
Sanders rallies and reshoot it totally
believes the crowd and booing Hillary
Clinton so this you can so here's the
thing you can get away with this in a
primary when you look like you're
running against the party establishment
there's what Donald Trump did in 2016
right he ran against the party
establishment he ran against Jeb he ran
against the so-called higher ups the
Romney i'ts and all of us and he was
able to capture that the party but in
the general election the party rallied
behind him simply out of opposition I
don't know as much as the Democrats hate
Trump I don't know that in the swing
states they hate Trump nearly that much
I think that most of the Democratic
hatred for Trump is in real blue areas
not in those purple areas I think Trump
is unliked
but I don't think that he's disliked I
don't think that he's quite as
polarizing as the Democrats think he is
such that they can be receded to leave
and win a national election on this
basis here's Rasheeda Talib who is
undermining unity inside her own party
actively booing Hillary Clinton leading
boos for the Democratic Party nominee
who won the most popular votes in 2016
talk about female solidarity here her
goes Rashida to leap directly after
Hillary Clinton Iowa we have three days
I don't remember if you guys remember
last week when someone by the name of
Hillary Clinton said that nobody we're
not gonna boo we're not gonna boo we're
classy here oh well boo
she's so long you all know I can't be
quiet no we're gonna boo
that's alright the haters the haters
we'll shut up on Monday when we went
okay and everybody is laughing and
everybody is cheering you know Han Omar
is laughing and Jaya Paul is laughing
okay that's amazing first of all I wish
I had a bowl of popcorn right here
because I would just be shoveling it in
my mouth right now just give me that
popcorn because the Bernie versus
Hillary thing didn't end it never is
going to end and the fact that Rasheeda
Talib ripped that scab right off because
she is the dumbest politician in
Washington DC
I mean she's truly awful it is it is
incredible and this is the Bernie
campaign this is the birth at the draw
of the burning campaign is we're
building a movement but the problem is
you don't actually see modulated Bernie
on the campaign stump you don't see that
in the marketing materials right there
the kind of its subtle Bernie that you
see on the campaign stump you don't
actually see that when you've got people
like Rasheeda to leave and Ilhan Omar
making this case so shooted Talib tried
to back away from this and suggest no it
was wrong for me to boo Hillary Clinton
I really shouldn't have done this and
then Michael Moore of course jumped into
the fray and defended Rasheeda Talib
there's a picture for you he says so
proud of my longtime friend from
Michigan who spoke the truth last night
at the Bernie rally in Clive Iowa the
audience booed Hillary and then somebody
tried to shoot them and Rashida said
don't shush them boo Hillary and anyone
else who doesn't speak the truth so they
are just ripping the scab off they're
going directly at the quote-unquote
establishment Democratic Party which of
course is scaring the daylights out of
the Democratic Party as they face up
against Donald Trump and this is what
the this is what the American people are
gonna see they're not gonna see Bernie
on the stump for two hours again I
watched that rally most people are not
gonna watch it to our Bernie rally
they're not instead what you're gonna
get is Bernie calling for the complete
destruction of the American Way of life
and his surrogates like Ilhan Omar doing
the same thing so Ilhan Omar was on the
stump for Bernie Sanders and she
described how disappointed she was to
see homelessness in America now let me
just point out this human being moved to
the United States who was taken in as a
refugee by a kind and generous country
from Somalia and she's complaining about
how unfair America is cuz she's seen a
homeless people here do you have any
idea how insanely ungrateful this is it
is one thing to say America needs to do
better to solve the homelessness crisis
I agree we do although the Powell she's
she's promoting won't do any of that but
for her to say
that she came here and she saw the
homelessness in America and she was
disappointed I hate to break it to ohon
Omar but half of Somalia is basically
homeless if not more I mean it is a
failed state it is a failed state in
which terrorist groups run rampant but
she was but hey she was 12 and she was
very disappointed that she saw a guy
living in a tent in the middle of Fifth
Avenue I mean really just just what a
tough life she is led I'm so the in
gratitude of the people associated with
Bernie and Bernie's and gratitude you
live in the greatest country in the
history of the world Mali can do is
about it it really a second thing
here xel-há Omar doing that when I first
came to the United States I remember one
of the first things that I saw was
homeless people sleeping on the sides of
Manhattan when we arrived in New York
and I remember turning to my father and
saying this doesn't look like the
America you promised and my front my
father said hush child we're going to
get to our America this is Josh child's
we didn't get to our America okay so
you're like what you came from Somalia
and your first move was I can't believe
I see a homeless person again like maybe
your first move should be what an
amazing country now we've got problems
here let's see if we can solve them but
if your first move is what a terrible
place I see homeless people you are from
Somalia my god I mean just how about
like a moment of gratitude before you
get to all the problems in America and
there are many before he gets that have
a like a moment of America's fantastic
because guess what America's pretty damn
is fantastic it really is this is the
part of the Bernie Sanders campaign that
is the seamy underbelly that the people
who feel like they're joining a movement
are missing which is that most Americans
actually like this country most
Americans don't think that the country
needs quote unquote fundamental change
that even Barack Obama subsumed his
fundamental change rhetoric beneath the
guise of a serious racial problem right
he said we need fundamental change and
then it was the idea that he and his
person it was the fundamental change
because he was half black and he was
half white who's gonna unify us around
race he didn't do any of that but that
was the fundamental promise when Bernie
Sanders says fundamental change you
don't need to decode what he is saying
his fundamental change is I want to
completely overthrow the way the United
States was created
I want to completely overthrow
everything about the United States I
mean the guy was literally drinking
shirtless in the Soviet Union
1988 I mean that's actual tape of Bernie
Sanders right this is this is who this
man is
so when he says fundamental change a
rational person says okay the
fundamental life change I see is the
fundamental change of destroying
capitalism destroying the greatest
economy in the history of the world
destroying carriage destroying free
markets and individual rights okay
that's what most Americans see now the
problem is in a Democratic primary that
ain't gonna hold in a Democratic primary
that's not enough to stop him because
the oat the only Democrats like really
there could be a Democrat who was
willing to come out this way and really
bash Bernie but they were all doing the
same routine that Republicans did with
Trump in 2016
truly I'll get to that in just one
second first let us talk about your
sleep quality so would you like to make
your sleep quality better I have a very
easy answer for you personalize your
mattress the same way you personalize
everything else we live in the Golden
Age of personalization right everything
is personalized to you your meal is
personalized to you everything is
personalized to you why should your bed
not be personalized to you your mattress
should be right I mean you're on it for
eight hours a night minimum that means
that you really should have a mattress
that is made just for you and this is
what helix sleep does he looks sleep has
a quiz it takes two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you it's fantastic I bought helix sleep
mattresses for my family you know even I
with this brain are going 24 hours a day
even I can finally bed down on a helix
ly mattress and get a great night's
sleep whether you're a side sleeper a
hot sleeper whether you like a pleasure
firm bed with helix no more confusion no
more compromising just go to helix sleep
calm /ban take their two-minute sleep
please they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10 year warranty you have to try it
out for 100 nights at risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will helix is offering
up to $200 off all mattress orders for
our listeners get up to 200 bucks off at
helix sleep calm /ban again that's helix
sleep calm slash man to get 200 bucks
off helix sleep calm slash man go check
them out right now okay so Joe Biden is
trying to fight the battle against
Bernie now the best battle against
bernie is going to be america is great
okay that we have problems yes we can
solve those problems together but
America is great okay that would be the
case the problem is the Democratic Party
has been spending so much of its time
set centralizing around the
intersectional ideal they can't make
this case anymore
so the intersectional ideal was here's a
bunch of minority groups who have been
his store
we put upon by the majority of white
people in this country and America
therefore is bad right we've created
this intersectional coalition and they
are pushing back against what America
historically was well what that means
that America was historically that it
means America current day is bad and
that means overthrow of the system when
you draw when you siphon from that well
when you're constantly drawing on that
it's very difficult to then turn around
and say listen America is pretty great
and overthrowing America as it stands is
a really bad idea and so you're left
with this weak T garbage you got Joe
Biden going out there saying how is
Bernie gonna pay for all this you think
anyone in the Democratic Party gives two
craps about paying for things you think
they care about this everybody right
left and center has been driving up the
deficit and insane race we have a
trillion dollar deficit this year you
think anyone cares about this good luck
for Joe Biden pointing out the Bernice
and Burt Bernie Sanders's plans are
irresponsible and never reachable this
ain't going nowhere if Biden's best
pitch against Sanders is he doesn't know
how to pay for this stuff that's not a
good pitch
the only kind of pitch though work
against Bernie Sanders is a case in
which you actually point out that Bernie
Sanders is Dennis Kucinich or that
Bernie Sanders is a radical who wants to
remould America and America is pretty
great in the first place but Democrats
have spent the last 10 years proclaiming
America is awful right this is the party
of the 16:19 project that means that
Biden's on the ropes even though Biden
probably is where the heart and so most
Democrats I really believe most people
who vote Democrat do not believe that
America is an inherently crappy place I
don't believe most Democrats believe
this and I think if you look at the
polls this is right most Democrats do
not believe that America is inherently
evil that was born in evil that America
is rooted in 1492 or 1619 in principles
of exploitation and principles of
slavery most Democrats don't believe
this but nobody in the Democratic Party
is willing to stand up and say this
because they are afraid of the media
blowback they're afraid of the
Twitterati
and they're afraid of Bernie Sanders and
his angry base so instead they're
relegated to making dumb arguments like
Joe Biden that he's fiscally responsible
you think again you think anybody cares
that Joe Biden is more fiscally
responsible and Bernie good luck with us
Bernie's dilemma from my perspective is
that he is not
being straightforward on how he's gonna
get done when he suggested the cost of
what he suggested okay good luck good
luck chiding Bernie Sanders supporters
on this is all pie-in-the-sky
many of them will say you're right it's
pie-in-the-sky but at least he's at
least he's consistent at least he's
dreaming big and unless you're gonna
present a conflict divisions you got
nothing which is why the Trump Biden
race the Trump Sanders race is gonna be
very different from the from the Biden
Sanders raise John Kerry yeah what this
means that if you've bought into the
basic premise that America is a bad
place that America is crappy
and America's historically evil and all
of that that America is not inherently
great if you bought into that then we're
just arguing over the boundaries of
spending and when he comes in and again
once you're arguing not over morality
but over but over accounting and
Bernie's got the advantage inside the
Democratic Party on that because again
no one in the Democratic Party has the
stones just say Bernie's vision of the
United States is wrong it is incorrect
nobody in the Democratic Party will say
that so instead you get people like John
Kerry who apparently was overheard by
reporters saying that Sanders was
talking drama parlor oh well the
difference between John Kerry and Bernie
Sanders is that Bernie says the quiet
part out loud John Kerry is a man who
back in the 1960s and early 1919 70s he
went to Vietnam he came back he threw
his medals over the fence of the White
House this is a person who went during
the Winter Soldier testimony and
suggested that American soldiers were
raping looting pillaging cutting off
ears electrifying genitals I mean this
is like torturing people right this is
what John Kerry said in congressional
testimony and then he became a United
States Senator on the back of this he
ran in 2004 and he tried to then run on
the basis of America is good and Bush
was like well yeah but all that stuff
about like what you said before what
does that mean the problem is once you
get in bed with the actual anti-american
left it is very difficult to get out of
bed with the anti-american left once
you're in bed with the anti-american
left you will be screwed it is just a
question of how so John Kerry apparently
was suggesting on his cell phone in the
middle of Iowa which is a genius move
then maybe he would jump in the race yes
I am sure that John Kerry would be able
to defeat Bernie Sanders in a way the
Joe Biden has not we needed another
octogenarian useless person that's what
we need John Kerry so fine John Kerry
tweeted out last night as I told the
reporter I'm absolutely not running for
president an airport
otherwise is effing or categorically
false I've been proud to campaign with
my good friend Joe Barton was going to
win the nomination beat Trump and make
an outstanding prep then he deleted this
has used the f-word and that was his him
being authentic so he backed off of that
but again the entire Democratic Party as
gradations of Bernie won through
gradations of Bernie Bernie has the
advantage you're saying this in
everybody from Pete Buddha judge who
used to proclaim that he was a moderate
to Elizabeth Warren who at one time was
in favor of school choice now they are
all just doing gradations of burning
alright listen to Ayanna Presley so
Ayanna Presley was out campaigning for
Elizabeth Warren Ayanna Presley of
course is the is the Congress person
from Massachusetts she's the sole member
of the squad who did not endorse Bernie
Sanders and so she was out there making
the suggestion that Elizabeth Warren
knows we live our lives in complexity
and intersectionality which is to say
America is a crappy place because again
in theory of intersectionality at least
when it comes to politics is that there
are a bunch of dispossessed groups and
that when you put them all together in
opposition to quote-unquote mainstream
America and the system that this is
amounts to the overthrow of the system
here's Ayanna Presley making the Bernie
Sanders case but doing it on the basis
of race as opposed to class Elizabeth's
got a plan for that but she's got a plan
for all of it that is true so how we
live our lives which is in complexity
and intersectionality and in nuance
she speaks my love language
she knows the power of the pin and the
power of policy she speaks her love
language is that gifts or is that like
um is that feelings like their five love
languages by the ways I don't know which
love language she's specifically if your
love languages and then
intersectionality you're doing love
languages wrong okay and just the second
we're gonna get to President Trump and
his take on all of this because again
trumps take on all this is directly anti
the anti Americanism of of Bernie
Sanders Reza is anti-american I mean he
literally believes the idea of America
is bad
he believes that America was founded in
evil he believes that America was built
on the on the backs of the impoverished
he believes that America is a story of
exploitation and and intersectional
grievance that that's what he believes
he just believes it more in a class way
than in a race way but the problem for
the Democratic Party is they were trying
to draw on that energy in the same way
that the Republican
party in 2016 was trying to draw on the
populist energy of Trump and so they
never took on his sort of bleak picture
of the United States and he ended up
cruising to victory in the primaries the
same thing is happening with Bernie
you can't crib off Bernie sheets and
then hope to be Bernie that's what
Elizabeth Warren tried it failed Biden
tried it in a very subtle way which is
he would sort of crib off of the
intersectionality America's kind of
crappy we've been ruined but Biden
should have made his pitch more explicit
right Biden's pitch was that America was
great when Barack Obama was president
now it's bad because Trump is president
now I'm gonna make it great again
it's a coin the phrase but instead he
couldn't do that he couldn't do that
because Bernie was out there basically
saying yeah but even under Barack Obama
none of these problems were solved once
you once you drink from the well of
intersectionality and political
grievance whoever drinks most deeply
what wafts most deeply from that well is
going to win the nomination right now
that looks a lot like Bernie Sanders
we'll get to president Trump's counter
pitch in just one second first let us
talk about your employees so let's say
that you are an employee with lots of
outside interests let's say that you
love whittling let's say that you are
you're a big fan and you're a big fan of
various survivalist shows and so you
just get up on those skills let's say
that you're obsessed with any variety of
topics ranging from Star Wars to watches
but let's say that you just don't show
up for your job in the morning right
like let's say that your name rhymes
with Nick let's say let's say that that
happens like you're really interesting
dude but you may not be all that
fascinated with your job well if you're
the employer of Nick perhaps you're
going to zip recruiter comm right now
and checking out alternatives to Nick
yeah he's an interesting guy but maybe
Nick would best be served by working and
like an outdoors company where he could
really hone his skills maybe he could
all like Carvin self a pan-flute or
something but not on your dime well if
you're looking for better employees
supercorps is the only way to do it with
results like zip recruiter brings it is
no wonder that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the very
first day they help you sift through the
candidates they provide the best
candidates to you
zip recruiter is indeed the smartest way
to hire here's the problem you open up
an application for a job you're gonna
get a bunch of randos and you don't
really have time to go through the Rando
so you want somebody to sift through
that for you make sure the best people
are applying for your job
that is exactly what zip recruiter does
check them out right now and you will
see how great they are tricep recruiter
for free at our web address zip
recruiter com
daily wire that is zip recruiter comm
slash Dai ly WI re zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire go check them out right
now and don't get stuck with employees
who would rather be out in the woods
pitching a tent instead get the
employees best for your company zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire okay in
just a second we're gonna get to
president Trump responding to the Bernie
Sanders surge and also to Bloomberg
because it turns out that Trump is
deeply worried about Bloomberg he thinks
apparently Trump thinks that this race
is not coming down to Biden and Sanders
it's coming down to Bloomberg and
Sanders which is kind of fascinating
also we'll get to all of the controversy
surrounding the Super Bowl which is
predictable and stupid every single year
we'll get to that in one second first
reminder we do have a daily we're
backstage tomorrow covering the State of
the Union address which should be a lot
of fun because I don't know that they're
gonna have completed impeachment
proceedings at that point right so Trump
may still be under a corn quote threat
of impeachment even as he does his State
of the Union address we'll be covering
that tomorrow live over at Daily wire
calm this is why you should subscribe
because you can ask us questions during
the broadcast and all of it gang if you
haven't noticed 20/20 its Wildman the
election race is just getting started
today's Iowa we know you need to know
everything from debate and primary
updates to the latest nonsense from the
Democratic candidates the best way to
stay informed is to become a daily wire
member and get comprehensive news and
opinion from us on demand so we are
giving you 20% off all memberships that
is 20% off all memberships when you use
promo code DW 2020 members get our
articles had free access to all of our
live broadcasts our shell library the
full three hours of the ben shapiro show
select bonus content access to the
mailbag and now my election insight
op-eds yes those are coming plus our new
all-access tier it gets you into live
online Q&A discussions with me Clavin
walsh knowles plus our sites writers and
special guests let us answer your
questions help you stay one step ahead
of the crew edit left if you haven't
already go download the daily where apps
you can get push notifications for
breaking news special coverage this is I
mean we spent an awful lot of money
creating this app just for you so take
advantage again check out promo code DW
2024 20% off your membership that's a
pretty great deal join today stay
informed on all things 2020 use promo
code DW 2021 you subscribe we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so President Trump for his part
obviously believes that this primary is
coming down not to Bernie Sanders versus
Joe Biden he believes it is coming down
to Bernie Sanders versus Michael
Bloomberg and he's pissed off at Michael
Bloomberg first he correctly calls Joe
Biden and he calls Bernie Sanders a
communist know everybody in meetings
like he's not a communist he's a
Democratic Socialist okay so let him
explain why capitalism is good really
like he's made he's made sort of weird
open-ended comments about why he's not
opposed to free markets but like let's
hear him talk about the glories of the
free market for a second before we grant
him that he doesn't want to nationalize
all industry how is it that no one in
mainstream media has asked Bernie
Sanders you know back in the 70s when
you were in your mid-30s okay we're not
talking about you're 17 when you're in
your mid-30s you ran at the head of a
party and called for nationalizing the
banks the energy industry and heavy
industry in the united states you still
for that and if not why not what change
did you realize I was unrealistic are
you looking for a transitional plan like
what exactly changed right here so when
when Trump says like you backed every
communist regime ever and also it seems
like a kind of a commie the reality is
he is kind of a calming okay here's
veers president Trump going off on
Bernie Sanders whatever comes to your
mind okay we'll start with Joe Biden I
just think of sleepy I just watch him
he's sleepy sleepy Joe Bernie Sanders
well I think he's a communist I mean you
know look I think of communism when I
think of Bernie now you could say
socialist but did they get married in
Moscow and that's wonderful Moscow's
wonderful Ben the honeymoon you don't
think necessarily well whatever but you
don't necessarily think in terms of
marriage Moscow okay that's all fair and
he's going to be hitting Bernie on all
of this right and this is what he should
be doing right he should honestly like
him going after Bernie on the fact that
Bernie believes that America is
inherently bad he's not a bad way to go
because most Americans don't believe
that America is inherently bad such that
it requires revolutionary Marxists
change which is what Bernie is calling
for meanwhile Trump is upset about
Michael Bloomberg so Bloomberg has been
spending all this money targeting Trump
hundreds of millions of dollars
targeting Trump he's been rising in the
national polls according to some
national polls he's running as high as
number three after Biden and Sanders if
Biden were to collapse then Bloomberg
presumably would be the inheritor of the
quote-unquote moderate mantle this has
led President Trump to go on Twitter and
say mini mag is part of the
they're all working together in fact
Bloomberg isn't covering himself to burn
to do or other Dems only Trump that
sounds fair
it's all the fake news media and that's
why no one believes in them anymore okay
all of that is fair except for the mini
mic part
I'm tired of Trump's I really like I'm
kind of annoyed by the the physical like
pencil neck Shiv mini mini mic like all
of this is such schoolyard nonsense but
from says many of the ads you are
watching were paid for by mini Magnum
Barry he's going nowhere just wasting
his money but he is getting the DNC to
rig the election against crazy Bernie
something they wouldn't do for Cory
Booker and others they're doing it to
Bernie again 2016 so here is from
militating in favor of Bernie right
Trump says he wants to run against
Bernie it's pretty obvious he wants to
run against Bernie and then he goes
after Bloomberg again calling him little
like if you're if you're chief diss on
Bloomberg is not that he's a government
nanny-state who wants to control
everything but that he is a little man
that he's 5/8 and that Bernie and that
because Michael Bloomberg like he
suggested yesterday that the DNC was
going to provide an Apple box for for
Mike Bloomberg to stand on it's not this
is all such schoolyard crap but whatever
man again this is the thing if Trump
could just withhold this for like a
second if Trump could just spend one
second and be like let me explain why
America is great and why Bernie Sanders
vision of America is garbage he'd win
walking away if he insists on going to
Michael Bloomberg is short what do you
think suburban women feel about that
seriously do you think suburban women
are like well now now that the president
said he's short I can't stand Michael
Bloomberg I don't like short men I mean
come on
he right here is going after Michael
Bloomberg and calling him short Michael
Bloomberg very little I just think of
little you know now he wants a box for
the debates to stand on it okay it's
okay there's nothing wrong you could be
short why should he get a box to stand
on okay he wants a box for the debates
why should you be in touch with that I
really didn't does that mean everyone
else gets a box
I guess if they're wall funny
interesting cory booker and all these
people couldn't get any of the things
that Bloomberg's getting now I think
it's very unfair for the Democrats but I
would love to run against Bloomberg so
your chief critique is that he wants to
stand on a box now maybe I'm over sent
I get a lot of height jokes I am five
nine by the way but I will say that
that's a weird critique like he
shouldn't be president because he wants
to stand on a box is a very weird
critique especially when you have he
tried to ban soda in New York City and
his policies on cigarettes led to a
crackdown on people selling loosies in
the streets like that like that there's
plenty to attack Michael Bloomberg on
his gun control agendas nonsense hey by
the way Michael Bloomberg been shot back
and exactly the way that you would think
that Michael Bloomberg would shoot back
now you have Bloomberg's campaign saying
that he is fat and orange so I guess
this is what we're going Bloomberg
campaign spokesman Julie woods head
quote he's a pathological liar who lies
about everything
his fake hair his obesity his spray-on
tan and then the former mayor said that
Trump lies about everything she
shouldn't be surprised he said things
like that I stand twice as ton's
as he does on the stage that matters
okay so now we're gonna get into fights
over who is fat and who is and who is
short and I guess this is what here's
the thing it's not as though we haven't
had dummies run for presidents of the
United States before and schoolyard
taunting in the presidency the
difference is it didn't matter because
the presidency didn't control so much of
American life this is why if you don't
like any of this join me over here in
the libertarian corner where we wish to
minimize the power of government so we
don't care what idiots are presidents of
the United States we don't care like
they don't bother us that'd be great
and I wouldn't have to worry about any
of this dumb-dumb stuff and the only
commentator in America wants to put
himself out of work by making you not
care about politics okay but apparently
like we're just gonna do it's idiocy all
the way down here is here's a Bloomberg
advisor mocking mocking Trump Mike
Bloomberg would eat Donald Trump alive
on a debate stage who knew that Donald
Trump was such a snowflake what's it
like to be in Donald Trump's head so
much and what I've said to people when
you get inside Donald Trump's head all
you're gonna discover that you find
there is a putter a cheeseburger a porn
video and somebody else's credit card
okay so okay so this is how it's gonna
go this is how it's gonna be and
honestly like I'm I'm not gonna pretend
that I think that it's like wildly out
of character for the Bloomberg people to
go after Trump Trump goes after
everybody else this way this is
you open the door to this sort of
schoolyard crap and this is what you're
gonna get it's it's immature it's stupid
it's nonsense but this is what we are do
I think that's effective for Trump I
don't I know I cut against the grain of
most Republicans who are laughing and
thinking this is a really wise and all
was in it can be funny and also stupid
funny and stupid very very possible many
movies are funny and stupid this is
funny it is also stupid it is not smart
politics hey well for their money both
Trump and Bloomberg ran ads during Super
Bowl so president so president Trump ran
an ad that was kind of fascinating in
its take he ran an ad on Alice Johnson
so Alice Johnson was was a sentenced to
serve life in prison for nonviolent drug
offense what okay to be fair she's
sentenced to serve life in prison for
allegedly running a drug smuggling ring
or being deeply involved in a drug
smuggling ring that was involved in
bringing literally I believe it was
hundreds of kilograms of cocaine into
the United States but I'm not messing
this up so it wasn't like she was
sitting on the street corner and smoking
a joint and then she ended up in prison
for a life like that is not accurate but
with that said it's interesting that
Trump is running his Super Bowl ad on
the basis of criminal justice reform as
opposed to just a rote patriotic ad
that's obviously him attempting to make
inroads with women in roads with
minorities it's an interesting take I
mean I'm not sure that I'm not sure I
love it I mean I don't love criminal
justice reform as a general rule I think
that criminal justice reform has been
wildly overstated in its in its
necessity as well as in the idea that
there are tons and tons of innocent
people or sitting in prison or tons and
tons of people who are who are sitting
past their their due sentences sitting
in prison but this was the ad that Trump
ran
it's a good ad for what it's worth
here's the ad says Alice Johnson was
sentenced to serve life in prison for
nonviolent drug offense thanks to
president from people like Alex for
getting a second chance
I'm free to start over politicians talk
about how no justice president from got
it done to thousands of families are
being reunited president Donald Jones
drop I'm Donald Trump and I approve this
message okay so here's my feeling about
political ads like this one I think it's
a mistake
for politicians to try to be what they
are not okay for Trump to play the like
I'm super compassionate card during the
Superbowl like what I am known for is my
compassion and reuniting a families like
it's true with regard to criminal
justice reform possibly it's also true
that criminal justice reform may end up
with more criminals on the streets also
you're never gonna be Democrats at this
game because Democrats just want to
Jailbreak Democrats are just like
everybody who ever committed a crime
should be out on the streets meanwhile
Michael Bloomberg ran an ad blaming
Trump for gun violence which again I
don't think that this is a particularly
smart ad either by Bloomberg but all
right on a Friday morning George was
shot George didn't survive
I just kept saying you cannot tell me
that's a child that I gave birth to is
no longer here lives are being lost
every day it is a national crisis does
2900 trillion every gun violence he's
been in this fight for so long
you heard mother's crying so he started
fighting when I heard my glass stepping
into the ring I thought now we have a
dog in the fight okay so it's a gun
control and on behalf of Michael
Bloomberg first of all that 20900
statistic apparently is not correct
apparently it's about half that but in
any case that's also a weird take from
Michael Bloomberg you would expect him
to run an anti-trump ad in the time when
people don't like Trump that was
actually his promise that him spending
hundreds of millions of dollars would
benefit the Democrats generally because
he'd be attacking Trump with all that
money that's not really an attack ad on
Trump so much and then again you have
the oblique ad from from very weird
takes for those Super Bowl ads from
Trump and Bloomberg but apparently Trump
believes that Bloomberg is sort of going
to be the replacement for Joe Biden as
Joe Biden falls out of contention we'll
know a lot more tonight meanwhile I'd be
remiss if I did not note that the Super
Bowl had another round of silly
controversies the dumbest controversy of
all of course was President Trump last
night deciding that Kansas City was
actually in the state of Kansas so he
originally tweeted congratulations to
the Kansas City Chiefs on a great game
and a fantastic comeback under immense
pressure he represented the great state
of Kansas and in fact the entire USA so
very well our country is proud of you
Kansas City's in Missouri so he got the
state wrong this led to a number of sort
of hilarious memes of the state of
Kansas with the Sharpie marks like he
did with the the hurricane path with
Sharpie birth to now include Kansas City
congratulations to citizens of Kansas
who now have taken control of Kansas
City without a shot fired that's
exciting stuff so this this of course
led to all sorts of dumb memes on
Twitter in sort of more important well
let's put this way more indicative
controversy surrounding the game the NFL
aired a patriotic display which they do
every year like I was at the Superbowl a
couple of years ago had a big patriotic
display before the game very nice this
is the dirty little secret is that the
NFL plays on everybody's patriotic
feelings because most Americans are
still patriotic right this is what Trump
should be honing in on not the criminal
justice reform stuff you should be
honing in
Americans sense of patriotism in
contrasting that with Bernie's sense
that America is an awful terrible no
good very bad place Beyonce and jay-z
refused to stand for the anthem now this
stuff is just irritating I'm sorry if
you want to talk about your problems
with policing in the United States you
are free to do so it's a free country
but this notion that you sit for the
national anthem in the same way that
Jackie Robinson faced racism Beyonce and
jay-z are facing racism as they sit
there billionaires and they sit from the
national anthem it's just obnoxious
garbage it truly is it's really
obnoxious and it falls into the Ilhan
Omar I'm ungrateful to be in the country
routine its you're free to do whatever
you want it's a free country but it's
gross it's gross I'm sorry jay-z and
Beyonce wow what what now this is jay-z
trying to buy it back because remember
jay-z had broken with Colin Kaepernick
the great hero of our time they and so
they were sitting for the national
anthem studiously doing so but she's
just again lucky very very lucky and
then there was the controversy over the
Super Bowl halftime show
do you get the feeling I get the feeling
the Super Bowl is not what it used to be
like a lot of people that I know who I'm
friends with like five years ago
everybody watched the Super Bowl I don't
know the ratings were this year yet I
just on a personal level I feel like
more and more Americans are like okay
this isn't what it used to be I'm really
not that into it as much as I was okay
so the Super Bowl halftime show happens
and every other year we have this idiocy
from the Super Bowl producers where they
decide to put on some sort of over
sexualized act this goes all the way
back to Justin Timberlake stripping down
Janice Jackson wearing a pasty I think
it was 2004 when that happens in over 15
years later and so last night they held
a striptease on the on the stage and
this was championed as feminism Inge
much feminism Inge because when I think
feminism what I think is not my wife
being a doctor and a mother what I think
is scantily clad women shaking their
asses for the pleasure of men that's
really what I think I think feminism is
all about this right it's all about the
shaking of the ass that's that's clearly
and everyone's like they are so they're
so empowered it's true nothing says
empowerment quite like stripping for the
pleasure of the hundreds of millions of
watching men and I know they're in great
shape congratulations that like really
good for you that plastic surgery and
exercise and restrictive diets are able
to do a body good like good for you
really that's a lot of hard work but can
we stop pretending that this had nothing
to do with sex or sex appeal like
there's a reason that Liz
wasn't on the stage shaking her ass that
way okay and like really there's a
reason the Superbowl cast it this way
there's a reason that JLo was doing like
actual whole dances right she did she
did a pole dance in the middle of this
in the middle of this right she actually
got up and she was like caressing her
own privates and doing a full-on pole
dance and girls aspire to something
better
there all these commercials about female
astronauts and then the halftime show
was was a sexy woman climbing on a pole
and doing a pole dance just wow just so
impressive and in every way I think
feminism go to medical school or be a
lawyer or be a mother or be a stripper I
mean that's that's just that's very
exciting stuff and listen can we stop
pretending that this was not a
striptease of course it was a striptease
the whole thing is performed as a
striptease like seriously the the so a
few things one it is not racist or
sexist to point out that this was a
striptease and is inappropriate for
children and that is patently obvious
you may have enjoyed the striptease more
power seats a free country you may have
thought that this was a wonderful
example of Western art alright I mean I
think that your taste is garbage but
sure but if but if you are going to make
the claim that this was somehow
appropriate for children or that people
who were offended by like I have a
five-year-old in the room and there's a
JLo pleasuring herself in front of
hundreds of millions of people like that
that is it's like I'm out of the box for
suggesting that this might not be
appropriate for a child or a young
teenage audience like when Shakira
dancing with a rope as though she is at
the deja vu nightclub is going to is
going to wait look at this like come on
come on like really
like she's good at shaking her hips like
that's congratulations but this it okay
with the close-up hit like okay it's not
just me okay I'm not just sick what's
funny is when people put on these very
sexualized accent when you pointed out
they're like why are you so concerned
about the set maybe what's in your head
what tonight how does the same thing
that's in your head what do you think is
in your head she's shaking heart like
the whole song is this what do you I
don't think that she's doing mathematics
she's not doing higher calculus she's
not sitting there doing your taxes like
what come on
so silly it's all so silly this is what
folks on the social left like to do they
will do things like they'll put drag
queens story hour out there and then
they'll be like why are you so offended
that words putting drag queens in front
of children it's because you're
intolerant and you're closed-minded it's
like well no I just don't think that
drag should be done in front of small
children that seems inappropriate for a
small children like cuz you're cuz
you're a a bigot what's in your head the
same thing that's you're in your head
which is why you're putting drag queens
in front of children or that you
wouldn't be doing it otherwise you
wouldn't think it was important to do
otherwise what's going through my head
why you think Shakira and JLo are stars
because of the quality of JLo singing
when he has nothing to do with her look
nothing at all why do you think she's
being celebrated last night because
she's because you think you think that
if this were just you know her standing
in front of a microphone singing like
normal and not jiggling her ass now this
would be getting the same sort of
attention don't be upset when people pay
attention to the thing you're begging
for attention from the left act like
teenagers they really do it's like they
dye their hair blue and they get three
nose rings and like why are you looking
at me why are you looking at me because
you're deliberately attempting to get
attention and then when I give you the
attention and you're like how dare you
give me this attention what's going
through your mind what what you wanted
to go through my mind is going through
my mind and then me saying that that's
inappropriate that's that's that the
only good thing that came out of this
silliness of course was um one great
meme which is Shakira decided to do the
thing that that I guess this is common
in she I'm not sure well what is
Shakira's ethnic background I'm not sure
what it is or a cultural background hey
she's Columbia okay so I didn't know
visiting Colombian culture is a thing
and likes to party Jewish culture right
like you'll you'll be at a department
store selling people great that's the
thing that people do at like a Bar
Mitzvah it's a celebrity noise so she
care actually did that on national TV
but it was weirdly sexualized
and so the only good thing to come out
of the Super Bowl was this meme of
Shakira doing this thing accompanied by
a goat doing this thing and one of the
better memes I have seen recently
oh this is so stupid our culture so dumb
we deserve whatever we get okay
come take us coronavirus come take us
okay time for the thing I like and then
we will do a quick thing that I hate so
things that I like today there's a movie
that I thought was actually quite good
very underrated Casey Affleck is the
more talented of the Affleck brothers he
also has more personal issues than the
other Affleck brother but Casey is
actually a really talented guy like his
acting is excellent he is he's a good
director he made a movie called light of
my life which is sort of a
post-apocalyptic film about a father and
a daughter who are braving the wilds of
a country where there's been some plague
that's basically wiped out all the women
and he has a daughter and so he's had
attempting to pass her off as a boy and
the movies really about fathers and
daughters I thought it was great
I really did it's called light of my
life it's very again like all
post-apocalyptic films
it's an incredibly pro-life film but of
course Casey Affleck would never
acknowledge that's incredibly pro-life
though because at the moment you
acknowledge that human beings must
survive as a species or that it is good
for them to do so you inherently imply
that life means something once you imply
that life means something then unborn
life also means a thing like there's a
whole scene where he explains to his
daughter how much it meant to him when
there's an ultrasound done of her and it
probably never occurs to people who
write these scripts that when they're
talking about ultrasounds and how much
it means an ultrasound it never occurs
to them at all that like these same
people will say then if you feel like
killing that baby you can it's amazing
but here's a little bit of the trailer
for light of my life which again I
thought was highly underrated and see a
lot of attention turned very much money
at the box office but it actually was
quite a good movie
don't they it's a safe place to be
for me cuz I'm a girl so the movie is
good I actually liked it better than the
road and a lot of people love the road
with Viggo Mortensen I thought this is
actually kind of a better movie so you
can check it out
were the worthy of the watch I think
it's on Amazon Prime I believe so you
can check that out okay time for a quick
thing that I hate People for the Ethical
Treatment of Animals are in the business
of making people want to eat meat just
despite them like all they do is make
terrible ads and say stupid things that
annoy me so I am somebody who is
honestly I'm drawn toward vegetarianism
I am like I know that certain popular
stands when I say drawn toward I don't
mean that I'm gonna stop eating meat
like right now cuz meat is delicious
well if if God didn't want to eat
animals you shouldn't made them out of
meat but with that said I'm drawn
ideologically to the idea of
vegetarianism it's there still I every
time I say this I get all sorts of
emails from vegans and vegetarians
saying there are no health drawbacks for
children there are health drawbacks the
source of protein in animal is much
better than the source of protein in
vegetables but in any case I'm somebody
who would actually be warm to the idea
for animal rights like I'm not that
animals have rights but that you should
treat animals with humanity I'm drawn
toward that even though I'm not an
animal lover it seems to me that
treating animals with cruelty is a sign
of great human evil and that if there
comes a future in a hundred years in
which people look back on things we're
doing today and they say that's barbaric
probably meat-eating will be one of
those things but PETA makes me want to
go out and just do nothing but eat steak
for the next week so they cut an ad and
the ad was not aired at the Superbowl
and then they were whining about it
which United the obnoxious virtue
signaling of PETA with Colin Kaepernick
so it's like all the things that are
garbage in one in one ad so here is
here's the PETA ad
it shows a bee flying over a valley and
[Music]
then the bee is taking a knee and then
they're playing the national anthem then
the bear is taking a knee and then the
fish are taking a minim knees I don't
know they would be taking exactly and
then you've got a wolf and a fox taking
a neat just like Colin Kapernick guys
and then a mouse and then a dog and
they're all taking these first of all I
don't need a dog feed a dog like I have
it lately a horse taking any okay and
the idea here and then a pig taking any
away so basically all these animals
taking any just like calling happening
and then a child taking a name because
we also we all kneel for the national
anthem because America is evil and bad
and then the American Eagle taking them
off because this this makes me want to
do nothing but he made nothing because
this is so uh it's respect is the right
of every living being is what it ends
with and speciesism speciesism okay I'm
gonna go with no human beings are
different than animals and if you don't
believe that is that remember the PETA
didn't add years ago called Holocaust on
your plate and I just thought to myself
you pieces of crap like the Holocaust
was an actual thing that happened with
actual human beings and if you cannot
differentiate between the quality of a
human being and the quality of an animal
and if you believe that they truly are
the same then you have a screw loose
this is what makes me want to eat
animals on an ideological level like it
once you say that I shouldn't eat
animals not because cruelty to animals
is inherently a bad thing but because
animals and human beings are in some
moral plain equivalent now you make me
just to demonstrate that animals are not
human beings Juanita cow because the
animals are not human beings and the
fact that people are attempting because
here's the thing once you start saying
that animals are human beings then
you're also saying that human beings are
animals and that ends in a lot of awful
ugly places throughout human history
okay we'll be back here later today for
two additional hours of content so stick
around for that otherwise we'll be back
here at tomorrow also remember tomorrow
night is our daily wire backstage live
coverage of the State of the Union
address which should be an awful lot of
fun will be rehashing I'm sure Iowa
looking forward to New Hampshire and all
the rest to go subscribe right now it's
daily where when you use DW 2020 you get
20% off our subscriptions when you
subscribe to get special access to the
backstage so daily we're backstage
happening tomorrow night go check us out
and we
see here a little bit later or tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director pavel white
house key technical producer austin
stevens playback and media operated by
nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by Mike Rowe Romina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 25 the Kansas
City Chiefs mount a fourth-quarter
comeback to win the Superbowl
NFL ratings are up finally and
Republican senators unexpectedly whip
the votes to exonerate president Trump
and end impeachment once and for all we
will examine the secret behind three
dramatic comebacks then Democrats
freaked out just hours before the Iowa
caucuses the halftime show highlights
the difference between sexiness and porn
and brexit comes off without a hitch
check it out on the Michael Noel's show
you